welcome to bananamores nico santos just
an electric comedian who will have you
laughing all day long
as you remember this hysterical set give
it up for nikko
thanks so much mitzi ah you look great
did you get some work done
yeah i could tell i could tell good to
see you
ladies make some noise
insert city here how you all doing good
okay
let's just get this rolling i've been
doing a lot of traveling
i know i just needed a change of scenery
so i took a little trip to my front yard
spent a couple of nights in my living
room i went on a shopping spree in my
closet
which i hate that place because they
never have my size my
boyfriend even took me to the hottest
restaurant in town
my kitchen uh didn't need the
reservation just walked in
food was great service was terrible well
actually tomorrow we're gonna try a new
place called
paw patrol postmates
i don't know if i'm saying that right i
think that's it i'm actually
old enough to remember when you had to
call in to the restaurant to get
delivery
and i always felt really embarrassed
because whenever i called in to order
food
i would always always order enough food
for like 10 people
so i would pretend like i was having a
party
uh so it wasn't embarrassing so i would
call the restaurant and be like
yeah hi um we just want the orange
chicken
and uh broccoli beef uh-huh yes yes wait
hold on one sec
what was that you guys what you
oh you want some pot stickers too what
else
and walnut shrimp okay let's put an
order of pot stickers and walnut shrimp
because these people
are hungry i know yeah uh-huh
uh-huh no one set of utensils is fine
thank you
yeah that's it listen i
know i talk a lot about food because i i
love food
i do i love food um a lot of people ask
me what my favorite food is
and i love all types of cuisine but my
absolute
absolute favorite thing to eat is my
feelings
i can eat it all day
i do listen i'm filipino that's why i
love food i can't help myself
it's in our blood you know filipinos
actually greet each other by saying
which means have you eaten so you know
it's just
how we are as a people we're always
trying to feed other people
fun fact if you actually look in the
mirror and say
candyman five times a filipino mom pops
up out of nowhere and tries to force
feed you laughter
oh it already it did
it i made that yesterday it's so good
just eat it food actually
saved my life one time it's true one
time i went to the eye doctor
and they were like listen is anybody
here to take you home because your
vision is going to be blurry and i was
like you guys it's fine i can see fine
don't worry about me i can do this so i
walk home
from the doctor's office and after
walking a few blocks
it happens my vision starts getting
blurry and you know what i was like
don't panic
girl don't panic you can do this you're
a grown man so i just
whipped up my phone i was like hey siri
directions to home please
and then siri was
and then like was like proceed to the
root
proceed to the root i was like that is
not helping
that is not helping so i'm starting to
freak out a little bit because
i can't see anything and i you know i'm
stuck there
so i called up a friend and i was like
girl you need to pick me up i can't see
anything
and i'm stuck somewhere and he's like
well
where are you where are you i'm like ah
i don't know i think i'm in the corner
of so
and so and so and so he's like that
doesn't help
and then as if an angel heard me
a breeze starts flowing and then i smell
something
and i was like hold up i know that smell
i know that smell and i follow my nose i
follow my nose
i walk left avoiding obstacles of course
i walk left i
turn around the corner and there it was
my favorite korean barbecue restaurant
it saved me food saved me i had
daredeviled my way
to safety and that is why i am alive
today
thanks to food
that's my time thank you so much
doesn't get any better than this guy i
literally did not
stop laughing the whole time this next
comic is gonna be your new favorite
please give a
warm banana moist welcome to
hello hello hello thank you so much for
having me
i am dwayne perkins oh wow
2020 was a crazy year and 2021 is just
right after it just giving the same kind
of energy so i've been just
really focused on self-care that has
been my thing
i have to because existing is
exhausting um and i wish that we had
like the ability to just have like
tiny little voluntary temporary comas
uh and we just like relax and chill then
we wake up refreshed ready to take on
the day i just realized
i was just dramatically describing naps
that is what a nap
is just a tiny small coma um that you
wake up from
uh you know what but i just you know i i
want them to be a little harder i want
to sleep a little deeper
that's pretty much what my whole
quarantine has been
naps and tv and also dressing like i'm
at a resort about to do a cover of mambo
number five
[Music]
um love lou vega
there's just been a lot of tv lots and
lots of tv lots of netflix
um did you know by the way that netflix
is ran
by this algorithm there's an algorithm
that dictates
the kind of cover art it shows you
depending on the demographic it thinks
you are and because i
am a black man who watches lots of black
themes they
tailor the art for that so for the show
sabrina which is about um a white
witch the cover art on my netflix menu
is
of a black witch named prudence she is a
great character
on the show but the show is called
sabrina
and then for a show like the office
the cover art is just stanley the the
black
sassy man then on the cover art for a
show like friends it just says haha boy
stop playing
um oh i've also been watching a lot of
disney plus i am a disney girl of disney
so much uh and there has been a lot of
discussion about the disney princesses
in the
zeitgeist uh but there has not been
enough discourse about the disney
princes
who are um not great let me tell you uh
so i've
been rewatching a lot of disney movies
and let me just go through a couple um
take
prince philip from uh sleeping beauty
he traveled thousands of miles
he fought a dragon dragon a fire
breathing dragon
just so he can kiss a girl in a coma he
did not know
problematic that is problematic it is
that's just what it is
um take a aladdin uh
street rat homeless he found a genie
lamp
he was uh granted the powers to make
three wishes and he could have wished
for anything
he could have wished for the end of
homelessness unless he was homeless but
what did he wish for
he wished to become a prince because
that was the only way he could get
with princess jasmine toxic and
malignant
don't like it don't like it and lastly
take um prince eric from the little
mermaid
he murdered an octopus woman of color
and for what so that he can be with a
girl
who did not have a voice and literally
could not say no
cancel he's canceled prince eric is
cancelled
disney none of these princes are good
role models but
i did find one who
to me represented the future
um let's step into a little film named
mulan
uh mulan decided that she had to go into
the army
to uh save her family's honor and she uh
cosplayed as a man and there was a
a young man by the name of lee shang who
despite her gender he was like you know
what
you're the one i love because he was
going off vibes vibes alone
and that is the future he is the role
model for all of us thank you so much
i gotta watch that set again let's
rewind the banana more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya oh
what a treat
i'm so excited to watch this next
performer light up
the banana more stage get ready for
comedy greatness
wow banana morris thank you mitzi thank
you
it's an honor to be here um really
you know quarantine is crazy right
guaranteed
the craziest thing about it though is is
everybody's quarantine
everybody's quarantined y'all think
about that everybody
morgan freeman is quarantining right now
narrating to himself 6am i wake up
the sun glistens through my blinds
10 a.m i go to the couch like i did
yesterday
and the day before that and the day
before that
and the day before that
10 35 a.m i passed gas
softly into the plush sofa cushions
you've heard of the bars of the penguins
but that was the fart
of the freedom
i spent too much time thinking about
celebrities in their mansions right now
i'm i'm in my tiny north hollywood
apartment for the last year and a half
will smith is in some wing of his house
going
oh man oh
oh damn where am i
no for real uh well i'm lost in my own
place i took a
wrong turn at the 37th bathroom
i'm sitting around miserable in
sweatpants every day
wow cat williams is in a diamond-studded
silk robe
just never in the history of copendom
has
a pimp ever quarantined with this much
bling okay
listen lockdown is a mess it's straight
doo doo boo boo
he just sips from a gold chalice
just a goblet with a pinky ring for a
handle
it's crazy i'm excited though i'm
excited to get out there you know i
can't wait to get the vaccine
i heard jb smooth got vaccinated yeah
yeah he was like um
you'll see i couldn't get the kobe 19
vaccine yeah black people get the coping
45 vaccine it's just a shot
that you have to put in a brown paper
bag
okay that's my time thank you so much
mitzi thank you so much for this this
opportunity i can't even get over how
much talent this person has
it's great to be here love you you're
beautiful all right
that comedian knows how to work a crowd
in my right